there are three debris on the way you
can three or four primary factors
firstly let's think about you because
alcohol is not going to affecting you
the same way it's going to pick the
person next to you or the person next to
them in fact everyone differently so for
you can you give me some examples of
things that were effect yeah
I can't down firstly wait they do call
it mass in the UM formulas that I'm
going to show you in a second says
helpful for the unit like that
wait that's yes certain age okay
interesting wait it's not not really not
really yeah okay thank you okay
so these two these are really we'll talk
about males generally versus an alcohol
Fausta what is a salsa
so even if you've got about a female who
are exactly the same mass they were
precise out the whole yeah that's right
so that's why all of this is estimate
all this area that's true that's true
yeah that's mainly about you this is the
two factors that affect to you is
another impact factor which is clearly
well just how much are you thinking
right
so you think more it's gonna effective
more you're gonna have a higher blood
alcohol content the way we define this
the way we quantify it is what we call
number odds they don't know what they're
called great thank you
I'll put that inverted commas I'm
putting this in inverted commas because
it's a technical term
right stay to drink mean this is
something I'm gonna show you exactly how
to calculate that in a second standard
drinks though in itself is affected by
two different things firstly it's just
quantity like how many drinks you take
like how many meals or whatever but
there's another fact that it's really
important yeah so the type of alcohol is
the time a drink and therefore what
percentage of alcohol is in there now
I'm pretty sure that the afternoon for
this sorry you started getting apnea to
death but it's because we're the secret
same same phrases I forget the acronym
you need to look for is ABV
it means alcohol by volume okay this is
generally a percentage so let me show
you some things here we go this is what
I'm after so standard drinks um you can
see here we're gonna open this some of
these for you in a second you can see
here for the typical containers that you
get beer or wine or spirits yes right
you've got different quantities that has
more alcohol
that's what if he you can see the
different quantities that result in a
standard drink okay now I'm sort of
running a little bit short in space but
I'm gonna try and get some was down B
you can see here I want you to have a
look at over here the left-hand side
you've got the alcohol by volume here so
that's why it's measured as a percentage
okay so to know for this amount of
alcohol rather misrata treat how much of
it is actually alcohol okay so you have
this ratio I'm just gonna save you right
now you might like to write this down
for the different drinks let me have
reached alcohol by volume is for B it's
about five okay you obviously have this
is range and you know from day to day
you'll get different you know day to day
batch to batch brand to brand you will
get different alcohol by volume but 5%
is a pretty good guy okay so when we say
B are you know like what do we mean mean
stuff like you know 4x
depending on it's gonna be towards the
hiring you know pure blonde kind of
reason all those kinds of things are in
this category of just be a roughly five
percent it's on the label I should point
out right not very large writing but is
that it's required by law okay
especially what's really goes okay now
if you want to if people want to drink
more like more in terms of quantity
right therefore people often get I'll be
a bit like you yeah things like that so
a light be generally again he's always
gonna be a rage is always going to be
arranged but they're a bath for yourself
you'll find these lots of different
breads out there like you know Han
Cooper's bones etc and they're basically
all quote like premium white like that's
what they made me it's okay so that's
how you can tell it's a light beer now
you can then see your next grade up is
wine okay now have a look at the
percentages that are listed there you
see how there's so much higher like
they're more than double okay the number
when I was researching approximately the
median I'll write this down the B and
ABV for wine is about 30 percent yeah
well they'll all very they'll all vary
but yes broadly speaking so you know a
nice sure is nice on your black whatever
they're all about around 13 you can see
they go up or down yeah yeah yeah it's
still in this it's still in this rough
range okay in fact pretty much all these
categories they're defined by their ABV
right once you hit you pass a bit a
certain threshold so now your fortified
wine and now your spirits I'll talk
about that aside what I want to point
out is can you have a look at the meals
you have a look closely at the bills you
can see for these containers there's so
much these glasses there's so much
smaller right because there's so much
more alcohol in them versus these okay
they're about half the size because
they've got about twice as much
concentrated alcohol make sense
yeah okay so how do you how do you read
this right so for instance if you're
drinking wine it's on the heavier end
fifteen percent alcohol right that means
all you need is a hundred and twelve
bills right like see all of this volume
up here it's just so you could swish it
around and write it's not to fill up
okay so your your 50% of wine your 50%
alcohol of wine usually to fill it to
there and that's already a standard
drink right so it's not much in the
actual so there so then so all of all of
these are about what is what cause it's
one standard drink so the next level is
not about if you've got fifty percent
the next level is well if you've got a
wine that has less alcohol in it
that's how high you fill it up to have
one stays yeah correct now by the way
can I just point out like for example
have a look at one of these okay no one
ever really terms how much of that thing
they've dropped because they'll you know
they'll get one right and they don't get
topped off or then you know someone will
add something else to it and so this
when I say estimate I really mean
estimate we're gonna talk about the
actual calculations but please don't
ever use that as a decision-making guide
this is the number that should be
important to you if you're actually
going to be driving okay this is about
driving safety yeah yes depends I'm
sorry I mean if you think about it what
that phone is those bubbles right it's
just the beer plus air it's all it is
right so it's still gonna have alcohol
content but obviously like once it
settles like we're talking about the
actual liquid
I probably towards yes right but no it's
very it is pretty fastest okay um now
I've got what I got right here might be
a wine they don't know what the last one
is I have actually already mentioned it
okay now there is fortified wine but
that's that's actually very it's quite
unusual of spirits which I've got a
complimentary does anyone know what the
two most common spirits are they're very
facing famous vodka and whiskey whiskey
there is to hear but vodka whiskey I
definitely have a comment now I've left
it off here what would you guess like
you can see things are getting better to
do this is brave damaged territory right
so yeah now I just want to point out
let's let's come back to this exactly
exactly
right these shot glasses right they are
tiny and they're not through the bold
way either right so you need an
incredibly small amount to cluster to a
single standard drink which is why
people get so drunk so fast okay so make
sense
that is bourbon is a type of whiskey
scotchy is oh you know what I don't know
I I know enough about drinks to I should
point out by the way you know I said
this is an important number it's not
just an important number for you it's an
important number for whoever is driving
the car you're sitting because we'll see
you guys are pretty pretty pretty
responsible why mostly you okay I know
it doesn't that's why there's designated
driver okay for me like the reason why I
know all of this stuff
so Victor Irie Irie is gonna probably
laugh at this one maybe should work
so most Asians don't possess the gene
for metabolizing alcohol properly so if
I create my dreams like 20 mils I'll
turn about about this car
okay now I'm not drunk I'm just super
super red okay so I don't I don't
genuinely I'm gonna enjoy the flavor
that much though I mainly know all of
this through my university days hanging
around with my friends and being their
designated driver so I don't really know
the difference yes correct
so this is the maybe that's the main
thing and by the way please look back at
what blood blood alcohol content is why
is bash so important
if you have like this yes and then you
add like two drops of whatever it would
be like more diluted but if you have
more D to be a man it's gonna be exactly
very good that's it you can see the
clear idea is if you wait more you have
more blood right so you have a larger
quantity a larger volume for which your
alcohol is there diluted damage is
exactly the right way okay so that's why
mass is so important